sony just isn't stopping when it comes
to new camera releases this year
this is one that i'm really excited to
show you because
right now this is the world's smallest
lightest full-frame camera body with
interchangeable lenses
and this new color option silver
[Music]
this is the all-new sony a7c
compact camera this is actually an
entirely new category for sony
is the compact camera line now this
camera is full frame
starting price is 17.99 for the body and
20.99 with an all-new 20 to 60
millimeter
f4 zoom lens they're also coming out
with some new smaller
compact lenses to go with this because
this is so light you want to have
a nice light lens to go with it i know
that it's incredibly overwhelming the
amount of cameras out there
especially just in the sony family but
when creators start looking for that
real
first mirrorless camera to upgrade to
i'm so excited
that this is now an option what's the
lowest cost i can get for a camera
without sacrificing too many features
is a question that i get so often and
i'm always on the hunt for that answer
i used to make a ton of travel content
and the camera that i would mostly use
was the
sony a6500 but this would have been the
camera that i would have gravitated
towards if this was out back then now i
know that the new sony a7s
is coming out very soon and that will be
my main camera of choice but the camera
is very expensive and it is a higher
end production camera and it's not for
everyone we almost always have a second
camera on shoots and because this
is so light this is going to be perfect
to put on a ronin or to use on our
sliders
or even just use as a second off camera
angle like this
let's also just come back to the fact
that this is a full-frame camera
a lot of the previous mirrorless
cost-efficient cameras have the smaller
aps-c
sensor so this will let you use
full-frame lenses and this will
significantly improve your photo or
video quality especially when shooting
in low light
and have i showed you this it's got the
flip out screen this is something that
is going to make
everyone's lives so much easier this was
the one deciding factor of why a lot of
people
ended up not getting a sony camera is
because when you are vlogging and
filming yourself being able to have that
flip out screen
is amazing now they tried to compensate
for that by
the 6400 having a flip up screen but
when you have a camera that has
interchangeable lenses
and a hot shoe for audio you're gonna
want to put a microphone on this
and when you put a microphone on this
flip-up screen just take a guess
what happened spoiler alert you couldn't
see the screen
thankfully a lot of these cameras do
have really good onboard audio so it
wasn't always necessary to have
when that a7 s3 with a flip out screen
was announced
that's it it's game changer now the size
comparison is what i really want to show
you guys
this is the sony a7 iii this is what i
pretty much use
right now for shooting everything in
between there
is the smaller sensor the sony a6400
so here they all are side by side and
the biggest thing about this is the fact
that this is a new compact form factor
as opposed to a 7 3. so the a7 s3
is a little more like this form factor
it is heavier so they've also moved
the lens piece over here to the left so
it does mimic more of the a6400 and more
in this alpha line this just feels so
huge at this point i mean you guys can
see the size difference in the sensor
here
i also really like the new body that
they have for this compact camera
this silver it kind of reminds me more
of like a vintage camera
but it just looks slick it looks updated
this looks like a real
20 20. well don't say it looks like 2020
but i'm just saying like a camera of the
time like an updated look
a nice new modern feel it almost kind of
looks like a
carbon fiber finish this does also come
in a black version as well but i really
do like the silver i think a lot of
people
are going to be into that do you like
the silver yeah tyler's into it it's
cool
you know what because it looks like an
old film camera right jenna is
facetiming me oh my god is it an
emergency there's got to be an emergency
hello what are we going to do about the
podcast what's wrong with you
what have you seen this before yeah it's
nice i used it it's
crispy what do you think of where the
menu button is located oh
menu button that was a really
great chat i like as they move the menu
button right here to the center like if
you
can't find the menu button you're
definitely not looking hard enough
oh menu button
so we have a headphone jack we have usbc
micro hdmi
sd card slot and a microphone input the
a7 s3 does have an all new updated menu
system
this one does not unfortunately because
that menu system is really really cool
someone is cutting grass
[Music]
here's where the battery goes and boy am
i excited
that they decided to cut the grass right
now so this will shoot 4k
30 and 24 and in 1080 you can do 24
30 60 and 120. this also has smq which
we use a lot especially for doing time
lapses or slow motion videos it'll
automatically perform them
into a video so you don't have to be
messing with a bunch of photos to create
a time lapse it will do it all
automatically for you in camera so this
is the old battery and this is the new
one this is the z series and
this thing is so much better than these
older smaller ones we would go through
so many batteries during a day that i
probably have 45 of these
crazy the good thing though is at some
point during my a7
s2 shooting days i got one of the ac
adapters and that's been amazing but now
with this
and some of the newer cameras like the
a7 iii that we're using and the new a7s
iii you can actually power those through
usbc and that is just i mean
[Music]
[Music]
it does have real time auto focus
tracking real time
eye autofocus and animal auto focus
which
you know we definitely use that quite
often with maddie so we're now out here
in santa monica taking some photos and
videos this is where i always come to do
our test shoots because it's usually a
really nice view but the air quality
basically in all of the west coast is
pretty terrible
today included so i'm gonna try to get
you guys some footage so you can see
what this looks like but
it's not very nice out today this is
shooting in 4k and one of my favorite
things
about the new updated sony's is the fast
autofocus are you ready tyler
okay ready was it fast
how's that focus
all right i better put this away before
i stab myself oreo
okay let's do a slow-mo test
so this doesn't do 4k 120 or 240 like
the new a7s iii but this still does do
hd 120 in snq
so that was an example of that what's
next should we take some photos
jenny will take some photos with me okay
cool photos
[Music]
now audio is something that you should
always keep in mind when creating
content and to help you monitor that
there is a headphone jack my favorite
thing though is the built-in hot shoe
this is the xlr setup that we use in
almost every single video we use the
sennheiser avx wireless microphones so
i'm wearing one right now
right here hello and this is going right
into the sony a73 that we're filming
with this is the setup that we use for
pretty much every video that we shoot
when we're out and about or sitting here
at the desk i
love having a wireless mic on and we
usually just use the shotgun for backup
now if you don't go the wireless lav
routes making sure you have a great
shotgun mic is very important there are
lots of options out there
like some of these when it comes to
getting external microphones that's also
incredibly overwhelming
these are the two that are my go-to's
when i'm shooting with sony cameras
this little guy is the ecm xyst 1m
there's gonna be a quiz later so make
sure you remember that this is the one
that i've been using
and pretty much the longest it's great
because it's super small it does have a
little shock mount so if you are
vlogging and moving it around a lot
pretty stable the one thing that i just
noticed
as i was shaking this around the a7s iii
has
these added little sound dampening
technology i don't know i think it just
made these a little bit more stiff but
you can't hear them
on the camera whereas this they they
don't have that so
normally what i do is i either take
these off or i will tape them so that
you don't hear that rattling around
in the body when you're filming but this
little microphone is great you can do
stereo you can move those around
depending upon
what you're doing whereas this one is
the
what kind of crazy name do they give you
the ecm b1m now this microphone i really
like
this one is a little bit more advanced
and it's also
way more expensive so if you are looking
to cut costs
definitely recommend this one do we
remember what that one was called
no i've only been using it for six years
yeah look at that
hey guys what's going on this is a vlog
a vlog jenna i'm trying to get some
cheese
uh we're sitting outside on the street
and having a meal because that's what
you do now
here in 2020 uh you can't go inside
restaurants but you can sit outside on
the
really clean street where people used to
park
i thought you're going to say something
else well they also do that as well but
i don't know i am loving this camera
though it's pretty pretty nice
we were talking to our friend farooq and
he said that this is kind of like
the sony a73 but in the a6500 body
could not be more correct yeah actually
boy is it quiet out here i'm having a
fine relaxing fine time relaxing time
having my meal
oh my biggest complaint with some of the
smaller cameras from sony in the past
were the smaller batteries
that they used you'd have to carry
around so many of these extras just to
make it through the day or
shoot this one though uses the new
updated
z batteries which will give you up to
140 minutes of movie recording or 740
images which is great news
because this also doesn't have a
recording limit for video there's a new
f4 20 to 60 millimeter that i'm really
excited to try out sadly i don't have it
with me here yet
normally for vlogging you want a really
wide angle and since this is starting at
28 that's not very wide
but i do think this will give you a nice
range for most situations if you're only
heading out with one lens but it's also
nice because if you do put it on a
tripod you will get that extra depth
with this lens
and of course it has a flip out screen
so you'll be able to see yourself and
you'll be able to make sure you're in
frame
so obviously we can use any other full
frame lenses that we have
and we have been shooting with sony
quite a while so guess what we've got
plenty of lenses to use
so no no no no no no no what
oh my god i just want you to know that i
actually for a second
forgot that there was a flip out screen
because i'm so used to when i grab a
sony camera that this is not
the amount of years that we've logged
with a sony mirrorless camera
and was just kind of crossing our
fingers hoping that we were in frame
countless you guys just don't know how
good you have it now
your vloggers of today we were in
struggle city
back then i'm just in the shot i can
zoom out we can see tyler in the shot
like this is oh i want to go into the
road trip and make a fun video
can't go anywhere on the west coast we
gotta go inward where do we go
arizona utah i would go to either where
should we go guys
we're safe we will be wearing our masks
i keep getting pushed uh
wyoming a lot i've never been for mike
posner's right now wyoming let's ask him
how it is
i see it on his instagram so the sun's
starting to go down
should we get a time lapse s and q one
frame a second
sure all right
[Music]
i'm not gonna say that this is the best
scenery that we've ever time lapsed but
at least we'll get to see a cool demo
and see how it works it's probably not
the best time lapse that we're ever
gonna do but at least we get to
see how it looks did you just say what i
said
thank you guys so much for watching i
look forward to seeing what you all
think about this camera and the fact
that sony is creating an entirely new
compact category
if you guys are new here be sure to
subscribe hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post new videos i have
tons of them coming up so
be on the lookout and with that i'll see
you guys in the next video
[Music]
you were in sq you handed it to me yeah
i know
it's weird that you didn't change it i
don't remember how to make a video